after surviving a box jellyfish attack
dr yanagihara recovers at home
the process is slow and painful after
three days of brutal agony and a week
total there was no sustained relief my
skin became you know terribly inflamed
all along these different tracks around
my neck was like rope burns i tried the
topical steroids and some other things
and and nothing worked nothing worked i
felt
really
curious
what
what happened to me
why did it hurt so bad what's the
physiology of this what's the
biochemistry of the venom
okay
you box jellyfish you you brought the
you brought the game to me
so now you know let me let me see
what makes this tick
following the incident dr yanagihara
dedicates her life to studying the
creature that nearly killed her
making breakthrough discoveries that are
crucial to public safety
there's not many researchers in this
particular species angel has done
amazing work
and established that the jellyfish move
with the lunar cycle every month eight
to ten days after the full moon
along waikiki
these animals would show up like
clockwork exactly on the lunar calendar
purposefully triggered in the pre-dawn
hours to spawn
her research not only helps prevent
jellyfish stings but has led to the
creation of a topical treatment
currently used by the u.s navy's special
ops teams
and for anyone who gets stung by a
jellyfish the remedy is simple
the best first aid
is two steps
first
flood the sting site with vinegar to
inactivate these little capsules so that
they can no longer fire
and that keeps things from
getting worse
second apply heat 45 minutes of 42 to 45
degrees celsius which is basically 112
to 115 fahrenheit
will irreversibly inhibit the venom and
change the course and now your body can
repair itself and you can recover
one of the things that concerns me is
when folks want to think of jellyfish as
nuisances or sinister or they're out to
get me i was crossing paths with
something that's been going on for 600
million years looking back
on all that i know now i understand that
i was in the wrong place at the wrong
time when i entered the water i was
entering their world and i crossed their
path so that was not their fault but
[Music]
you